this is a big new idea so I'm going to
introduce it to you by defining it
because you can't really understand you
can't work with these things unless you
know what they are so logarithms da da
dun ah a way of looking differently at
Exponential's or indices okay
now this does not answer the question
for us this is a very vague sort of
definition but hopefully it will if I
give you an example attached to this it
will show you exactly what I mean
so it's about looking differently it's
something you're already familiar with
Exponential's indices powers these are
things you've been dealing with since
mu7 as an example 2 to the power of 5
don't tell me the answer tell me what
that means this is an abbreviation for a
particular kind of operation what is it
an abbreviation of yeah thank you
yeah 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
right if you do it that number of five
times what do you get think 2 4 8 16 32
okay so that's 32 so what you're doing
with an exponential like this that's
called the exponent or the index or the
power all different words for the same
object what you're doing is you're
looking at something and you're saying
ah
it's like a thing that's doubling in
size right 2 4 8 16 32 64 128 and so on
and it's growing and growing and growing
so it's kind of like this is like a
growth rate it's like a growth rate if
you like
the five is sort of like well how many
times did you do that doubling thing how
many how much amount of time did you
grow for this is kind of like a time if
two doubling is your growth rate and
five is how long you are doing at four
what's the meaning of 32 the result the
final result if you were growing ago
you're going right then you'll end up
thirty-two times bigger than what you
were when you started if you were
doubling and you did it for five years
or five minutes or whatever it was
now before we move on to what this log
thing is I want you to see how this
analogy of time and growing helps us you
know the index law for this you know the
index law for this
soon to the power of zero anything to
the tire zero is now think about what
that means what that means is your
growth rate is doubling not a rhetorical
question how long how much time did you
grow for look look look you haven't
grown at all so therefore what's the
result the answer is one 100% you're the
same size that you were when you started
right think again you've got another in
debt wall you know of what is that mean
when you've got negative power that's a
half isn't it okay now think think about
what this means with this analogy this
metaphor right you're growing rate was
doubling how long into the future did
you go how long did you wait well this
means instead of going forward in time
or not going anywhere in time you've
gone backwards in time which means how
big are you were you're half the size
because you're in a growing machine
you're in a doubling machine does this
make sense to you okay all right so here
I'm going to take this analogy and now
I'm going to write each one of these
instead of writing it in exponential
form
I'm going
write them as logarithms and I'm going
to ask you to help me work out what they
mean instead of writing logarithm we
just write logs because it's shorter now
I would write this let me read this out
for you and explain what it means the
way I would read this that choose a
subscript it's a little too is I would
say log base 2 it's a basis down the
bottom of 32 equals 5 that's the way I
read this mathematical sentence log base
2 of 32 equals 5 ok I'm going to write
down this one as well log base 2 of 1 is
0 log base 2 of 1/2 is negative 1
ok so what is this thing
we've changed perspective we've looked
at it differently I've just kind of
taken the same numbers 2 5 and 32 and
I'm just kind of shuffled them around
and move it okay remind me again what
was this - it's your growth it's it's
how fast you're going
what was this they - it's when you end
up that's how big you end up being so
therefore what this equation tells you
is if this is how fast you're growing
and this is how big you end up how long
were you doing it for what was the time
that make sense let me say that again
because such an important idea if you
know how fast you're growing and you
know how big you end up can you tell me
how long did that take if you're
doubling and you end up the original
size that you were how long were you
growing 4 odds are you didn't grow at
all right there was no time there
passage of time you're that big right
now if you're growing at this rate
you're still doubling when was i half
the size that I am now
and the answer is in the past and they
give no bar right I go backwards in time
so think about it this way I'll give you
an example let's change the base this
time if I say log base 3 log base 3 of
saying 81 I'm not in a doubling machine
anymore I'm not growing in a doubling
rate I'm tripling eventually after
tripling for some amount of time I end
up 81 times bigger than I am right now
so how long did it take me to get to
there 3 9 27 81 so it took me 4 steps if
you like so therefore this is 4 this is
a log equation a logarithmic equation I
can do the same thing I did before and
rewrite it in reverse order I can
rewrite it without any logs but just as
an exponential equation how would I do
it
I don't shuffle things around the bases
say the same in fact we call these guys
bases right so the base there will be
the base here 3 the power of 4 is that
guy these kind of swap places that's
going to be 81 which of course your
calculator can verify okay